okay let's just let's just do it let's
make like an Ike and just do it no no no
you know your life is different now I'm
34 years old I've lived in a lot of
places and I know that where you live
can be a very direct reflection of who
you are as a person
I live in New York before I lived in LA
and I bounced around to a bunch of
different apartments and then it layout
lived in like four or five different
places so with all of my experience and
expertise I figured it would be wildly
selfish of me to keep all of these
treasures of information to myself so
today I'm gonna teach you how to trick
people into thinking that you live in a
mature cool adult living space get rid
of the futons and bring on the croutons
when you have croutons in your cabinet
it really says that you're an adult
because like you're making a salad and
you have your own croutons like children
don't do that babies don't do that
adults do that you need a coffee table
tray one of those trays that sits on top
of your coffee table where you stack a
bunch of sheets on it so that that [ __ ]
doesn't touch the actual coffee table it
does not have an actual purpose but it
looks purposeful look at you you have
like designer OCD none of your decor is
touching the table
that's how germs get spread you know who
puts decor directly on a coffee table
the children you know who puts it on an
unnecessary tray on top of their coffee
table adults with that you gotta put a
book or books on that tray and books say
you're never gonna read no no these
aren't reading books these are looking
at from a distance books you want people
to come in and go oh wow
a book this person I think has the
ability to read you know who doesn't
kindergartners know who does most adults
wham bam thank you ma'am a disorganized
pile of seemingly important unopened
mail this is just the standard for every
adult home you have to have this to be
considered an adult when I go into
someone's home that has a pile of
seemingly important I'd open mail I
think look how sophisticated they are
they get mail and they must be so busy
and in demand that they have no time to
open up these 17 letters from Athena
health insurance I want what they're
having and the more don't you are the
more piles of seemingly important
untouched things you'll have it's just
math just like a picture with a broken
arm your house needs an uncomfortable
throw every adult home has an
uncomfortable irregularly sized blanket
that they've thrown on their couch it
doesn't fit the size of an adult human
being and if material is usually
something that makes your body each feel
wildly uncomfortable that's what being
an adult is nothing fits and you're
always kind of uncomfortable you know
who doesn't have tiny issue blankets
children actually they do a cutting
board truly an adult masterpiece if
someone came in and saw a cutting board
in your house they feel like all right
you must be old enough to rent a car
John don't use cutting boards they use
countertops a countertop is technically
a giant cutting board for babies and
bonus I recommend getting a wooden
cutting board because you just throw
some meats and cheeses on there and you
got a fish a kutari board you know who
loves Shakuni every adult person I've
ever met
it's just one big giant sloppy lunchable
but adults think it's fancy a trash can
next year and toilet first of all you
should have a trash can all adults have
trash cans you don't get into the pearly
gates of adulthood without showing your
trash can but a trash can next to a
toilet that's some next-level adultery
adulting you don't know how many times
I've been at someone's house and I've
had to change a tampon and I've had to
like put it in my purse to find a trash
can later uh-uh
real adults put trash cans next to their
toilets because who knows what's going
in and out of anyone's body and they
need to dispose of the remains it's just
a game changer it's very adult also
sometimes I don't some puddles of water
in the corner of their bathroom that
they don't know where it came from
that's just an adult thing don't worry
about it if you don't get it your child
and I already clicked in my settings
that this video is not for kids so I
don't know what you're doing here chip
clips okay I just learned in the last
year that chip clips are where it's at
chip clips are an adult thing I've gone
to the stage where I've purchased chip
clips have I used them for the
overwhelming unnecessary amount of
snacks that I have in my house no I'm
getting there baby steps
I mean adult steps mature woman steps
people gonna be like look at you I guess
you don't
bugs in your food you know as bugs in
their food children one time I was
eating a box of cereal with my hands
just dry for like five minutes and then
a bug flew out of it and I kept eating
it those are my carefree days I'm gonna
dope now and I have chip clips that I
look at and think about using art you
need art I'm talking arts art art art
art arms and candles my god you need
candles candles candles candles candles
candles like suddenly your place it was
like a snappy personality and some
competing odors it's basically like a
high-end escort and you know who can be
high-end escorts adults babies can't
thank God
side tables adults can love side tables
yes you can put your drink on a coffee
table but why not have some options you
can even use that side table to hold
some seemingly important unopened mail
you can even put a plate handle on top
of that seemingly important unopened
mail on top of that side table wow if I
came into your house and saw that I'd be
like this person pays taxes when I lived
in New York and I was still a immature
idiot with an apartment I never had side
tables you know what I had a floor my
floor serve double duty as all tables
and also a floor Oh extra toilet paper
near your toilet this is such a smooth
adult move and let your guests know like
hey I know like SIBO and IBS are very
trendy for everyone right now and you
might need some backup you don't have to
use the roll you don't have to use a
makeup wipe you don't have to dig
through your purse and find like a CVS
receipt no I got backup toilet paper for
you we're all adults here we don't use
our sleeves anymore for that [ __ ] with
that tissues having tissues anywhere in
your house it's such an adult thing to
do this makes your guests think wow when
they're sick they have a separate paper
product to blow their nose they're not
just like snot rocket in in their shower
using paper towels or old underwear I
guess I've entered the king and queen of
maturities helm a security system this
is a very adult thing the world is a
dangerous place and you want to make
sure you're protected and yes I do have
a bat shaped like a cane directly next
to my bed I'm sorry that I've reached an
echelon of maturity that some of you
will never even know exists a decent
comforter for your bed
want to know that on the days that you
wake up with unexpected crippling
depression you can just sink in and
wallow in your own anxieties in comfort
in style that we can cry ourselves to
sleep in like a cute Pinterest way I got
some ratty old $20 makeup stain
torn come covered duvet ah speaking of
comforter that comforter is a Buffy
comforter and they're sponsoring this
video today I love them Buffy sells
comforter sheets pillows all the
products are made from super soft
eucalyptus fibers so everything is cool
and breathes and is more comfortable and
softer than cotton it's wonderful and
because it's made from eucalyptus it's
basically like temperature controlling
so you never get overheated and for
someone like me who gets the night
sweats because I'm an adult
adults get night sweats it happens
sometimes when you do dry January you
sweat in the middle of nights because
your body's detoxing and you know who
can't do that children because they
can't drink legally I'm off track
all about these products are
hypoallergenic and cruelty free no guilt
the company has over 17,000 five-star
ratings so I'm not alone in thinking
they're great we don't have a free trial
free shipping free returns free free
free fruit and the eucalyptus fiber
isn't just softer it's also earth
friendly it's sourced from renewable
forests and it takes 10 times less water
to grow now you can get $20 off your
buffy bedding if you click the link in
the description and use the promo code
and now you can get $20 off your buffy
bedding by clicking the link in the
description box below and using the
promo code grace I truly love this
bedding it makes me feel like a capable
functional adult that's all we're going
for well there you go
there's my list of things and stuff that
you can put in your living space to
trick people into thinking that you have
an adult living space so your
sophisticated Sybil I revolve your you
got toilet paper make sure you subscribe
to this YouTube channel I make videos
you know here and there other than that
I don't know